11 juillet 2021 jour du sacre de
l'italie à l'euro face à l'angleterre
jour également deux victoires pour le
malien la coupe des nations mantaise au
terme d'une finale qui a fait le plein
au stade jean paul david mantes-la-jolie
l'équipe s'impose 3 buts 1 contre
l'algérie la joie des supporters au
rendez-vous grâce à des buts de
coulibaly un doublé de baradji le mali
succède à la république démocratique du
congo au palmarès de la compétition
c'est tellement chose que je ressens que
je peux même pas décrire ce que j'ose
que la victoire que le mali mali
puissants sea mali puissant si un
nouveau succès pour la coupe des nations
nantaise qui revenait pour une deuxième
édition à mantes-la-jolie pendant un
mois 16 équipes se sont affrontées pour
la victoire finale de la france au ghana
en passant par le portugal et la tunisie
[Musique]
souvent
ils sont joués avant le coup d'envoi les
matches se disputent devant une tribune
qui pouvait accueillir jusqu'à 3500
supporters
une grande fête organisée par
l'association jeunesse et diversité
après les nombreux confine c'est un
moment on se retrouve
c'est un moment qui lui permet de penser
à autre chose de pouvoir passer des
moments aussi en famille parce qu'il
faut il ya des familles qui sont ici
présents et des enfants
le maire qui est là les autorités donc
c'est une fête pour toutes tout avis de
montage ou est un moment très apprécié
par les spectateurs mais refuse ça
permet aux jeunes qui restent dans la
cité de s'éclater c'est pas nuire c'est
le mélange des cultures
c'est bien ça nous permet de tous nous
réunir et voilà de permettre aux jeunes
qui font pas en vacances de profiter un
minimum la coupe des nations mantaise un
événement déjà installé à mantes la
jolie le rendez vous est d'ores et déjà
donné en 2022 pour la troisième édition